I thought at least these three questions
could be part of our conversation later
after we I want us to get up and
actually create a public work but I've
been thinking about how my contemporary
art and social practice enable
conversations about difficult subjects
and that's part of what we're interested
in couldn't that be the focus of a
curriculum a multi-week a multi session
unit of instruction with learners of
many a range of Ages and in the range of
spaces or why prepare teachers as agents
of positive social change I mean some
people say oh we have to prepare the
fair but why what would come out of that
or why not what does it mean maybe the
question should be what what does it
mean for teachers to be prepared as
agents for social change some of you are
studying in departments or programs
where social change social activism
positive social responsibility is
essential to the mission what why do
that is that's such a good thing or how
can creative responses to social
injustice interrupt conditions of
inequality I might not be able to change
them might not be able to stop them but
maybe it interrupts it just long enough
to reposition or find other ways other
tactics other approaches to engage I
think this is a good time to stop and
let's get up and let's make some public
trouble I brought with me some
children's books and I also brought some
children's toys how many of you brought
cell phones how many of those cell
phones take pictures oh yeah now we can
work is individuals we can work in pairs
or trios if we want all right I have
some children's books here I'll share
them show these with you to you not all
of them deal with uncomfortable stories
some of them do there's a whole range of
things like Flat Stanley on if you're
snow the Flat Stanley to me there's a
Henry box Brown deal here where you can
mail individuals to different place here
he's pretty happy about going to visit
his family but Henry couldn't do that or
the big orange
but this is about one house being
different and then I won't ruin the
story for you at the end but it's about
finding your own way little blue and
little yellow I don't know if about know
if you know their story but when you mix
blue and yellow you get green and what
does it mean to be blue or yellow and
how does mixing happen tar Beach about a
little girl who she doesn't have
something or can't go somewhere she just
imagines that she can fly there and she
can capture that experience bell hooks I
don't know if you know her children's
book skin again there's a wonderful book
about distant learning disabilities
reading in particular it's called the
art of miss Chu where the art teacher
her art teacher essentially figured out
she was seeing the world differently her
reading what issue is reading she was
reading the spaces between the words not
the words themselves just like an artist
might try to render the negative space
rather than the positive space or Maya
Angelou poem and a jean-michel Basquiat
poem put together jean-michel Basquiat
images and Maya Angelou poem life
doesn't frighten me anymore these are
children's books that I found kids
respond to in interesting ways so you
might choose one of these books and find
one of those unexpected public spaces
where you don't think education or art
making or art practice is supposed to
happen you could take one of these books
and go and read it there outloud and
have somebody else or yourself videotape
you or not videotape that's you can tell
them make a video of mobile I sell a
mobile video of you and you can put one
of the hashtags where's where our
hashtags Steve there's you can hashtag
it and pop it up on social media if
you'd like or you can take still photo
of yourself or someone else reading out
loud we can take several document that
experience what would be interesting is
is to see what kind of social
interaction happens and think about the
critique remember those little tiny
townspeople and the tiny presidents the
critiques of the store
of the little people and the stories of
those spaces there's a conversation that
happens think about the story you might
read in that space in relationship to
that space or I have these little toys
just three firefighters two of whom have
razor stubble one has a mustache
I wonder how gendered this is I'm just
asking questions right now or little
animals or I had little LEGO Minifigures
they these have to be put together I
mean you're welcome to take them and put
them together and use them in the ways
that you saw in the photographs
critiquing having a conversation in a
public space that story where's my
Henry's freedombox I think I'm gonna
take one of these pallets I can't take
both of them I'm gonna take one of these
and I'm going outside I'm gonna read
this book I'm gonna perform that story
outside
Henry was lonely one day he met Nancy
for the shopping for her mistress they
walked and talked and agreed to meet
again
Henry felt like singing but slaves
didn't dare sing in the streets instead
he hummed all the way home Henry knew
they were very lucky they live together
even though they had different master
[Music]
I can admit Oh
I think beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
does anyone want to talk about you want
to talk about your own specific
experience either reading a book out
loud in public or reading a public space
with a conversation with your figure
mainly people ignored me some people
like you said made it sort of a wide
like somebody came realize they were
sort of in the scope of the photograph
and I'm so sorry oh and you were taking
the photograph and you said never
thought was okay you can go in no no no
I am I to do
so that was a I used to love to read
children's books to my kids so it was so
I mean you know it's just so much fun to
be out there and showing everybody and
and some people who looked into it and
some people smiled and I saw people sort
of taking pictures and then I was
watching you and I saw somebody like
doing posing walk to the side in front
of you like wanting to have a picture
like they figured this is some like
thing and they wanted to be in it but
not really in it so they were all on the
side always they want you family though
if you don't even know what ID is why
I'm just so desperate to get a picture
Nicolas MERS off visual culture scholar
uses the word sublime to talk about
those visual moments or those moments
that are so repulsive you can't look
away and so seductive you can't bear to
look at it you know I mean it's that
tension everybody calls that the sublime
so maybe there's something sublime about
that that they wanted to be part but
knew something was going on but they
weren't supposed to be part of it
[Music]
and maybe we see the little Lego
goodness playing with a hatchet of
course and so we were playing around
with whether you had the hatchet or not
have time today giving him like on
different pictures from magazines or
newspaper and he was in different
contexts and they put him on the water
bubbler and it's playing with him in the
water bubbler but it was interesting and
I did think about my kids that have a
lot of fun my students a lot of fun of
it
so the hatchet tell me about why with
and without the hatches is like
accessorizing or I was like we had him
in front of his headlights and according
to the headline if you have a hatchet
the headline meant one thing but if he
didn't than a minute different things so
that context changed once that weapon
was introduced can you give us an
example of one of those headlines
someone won an award and we play in
front of that with that with the hatchet
which made it a little bit more ominous
and then without the happiness like well
you're playing with the various symbolic
meanings that are referenced but not
just the ninja but with that hatchet and
the text so there's the layered readings
and even that subtle seemingly innocuous
change of hatchet or not hatchet shifts
readings shifts shifts meaning there
it's very powerful I hope some of what
we've talked about gives you beginning
points or places of departure for your
own work as educators or artists
continue this this work see what else
you can trouble what other kinds of
questions you can ask what other stories
might be told maybe take the little
figures and go make some more imagery
maybe find them fire hose or attempt
other performances maybe this is an
assignment that would work for with your
students and give it a shot and if it
does or if it doesn't maybe sure social
media drop me a line we'd love to hear
what you're up to as a ripple from what
we're doing here I said yesterday and
last week as an artist as an educator as
a researcher I have found that I'm more
interested in
changing the answers than I am in
answering the questions for me the
answers are the social constructs those
practices those systems that people have
put in place sometimes remaining
unquestioned or under analyzed and maybe
art-making through social engagement is
one way to provoke reflection hoping to
discover something in the process about
those constructs I'll leave you with
this the National Education Association
is a professional organization in the
North America it's open internationally
primarily made of k-12 art teachers but
there are other educators aren't
educators in the group higher education
professionals museum educators there are
two journals published studies in art
education which is essentially the
Journal of issues and research in our
education and then art education which
is essentially for primarily for k-12
and museum educators and each issue they
typically have six articles in here and
then an instructional resource but this
particular special issue that came out
in July of 2017 it's a special issue and
the theme the call for the theme was
creative activity as a human right and
the editor said you know instead of
getting six all I see isn't how many I
can get so he cut down the number length
of the submission of these shorter
pieces but they're really open to little
pieces there's so many in here one of
the articles in here is called socially
engaged art education practices
processes and possibilities and it's
about ceramic water filters public
performance socially engaged art and I
co-authored this with two colleagues
Ross Ross Schlemmer who is a professor
of art education in southern Connecticut
and Ericka Hitchcock who is a high
school art teacher in Virginia Beach and
so the three of us put our voices
together to talk about our experiences
here the other piece that I want to
share with you it was was one that was
written by
three art educators at Maryland
Institute College of Art in Baltimore
you want to read the opening paragraph
to you and then another excerpt in them
we can have a final set of comments
there article is called Baltimore
uprising empowering pedagogy for change
and was written by vanessa lopez adrian
Pereira
and Schuyler au the Baltimore uprising
was in response to the death of Freddie
gray
who was fatally injured in April 2015
while in police custody in Baltimore
City the first evening of the uprising
we were home glued to the television
communicating with each other and our
pre-service teachers worried about
violent protests that were erupting in
parts of the city that's one of those
moments within your own community that
changes the community certainly now
Freddie Gray's name is is well known and
so these three art education professors
who were working with pre-service
teachers we're faced with this real-life
situation and what is our
responsibilities aren't educators as
artists as teachers as citizens within
this community to prepare our teachers
to to to face these issues in these
situations and how do we do so
responsibly not only as community
members and related to them so these
teachers as our students but knowing
that these folks are going to become
teachers who might face similar
situations they constructed a pedagogy
they call it a pedagogy for change
framework I just want to read briefly
what they wrote and then and then open
up because I think this piece speak goes
to the heart of what this theme for this
week has been dealing with difficult
situations and challenging social
constructs primarily in this case police
brutality there's elements of white
supremacy and racism that flowed
throughout as well they said we if we
alongside our pre-service teachers
engage with self as the
first piece so there's four components
ourself to understand the intersections
of identities from our lived experiences
examine through the lens of the
historical context of established social
injustice 'as in schools and communities
context being the second then we have an
informed understanding of these
complexities that three students
contribute to the cultural assets of
every classroom with the goal of
developing a critical for pedagogy for
effecting change
we're Dean necessary so the combination
of self not only teachers but also the
selves of the students we need to
understanding of the context social
cultural political locational and
bringing the students in there as
cultural assets within the conversation
perhaps a formula the pedagogy emerges
from that that formula I think it's a
brilliant piece and then they walk
through each of those components for you
you